[Music]
okay everybody so this
is my review of season four episode
three
of the handmaid's tale the crossing this
is written by
showrunner bruce miller and directed by
elizabeth
moss which is really really exciting to
see what she's got in that field
so usually in my reviews i break it down
by different plot lines but
this story was really mostly the main
plot and this episode kind of follows a
straight line so we're just gonna go
scene by scene here
now what i love about the world of tv
today and
having all these social media reactions
and having fan bases heard and read it
i love that now shows
can see what fans are saying more now
and what they really want and make some
adjustments still staying to their
creative standards and keeping their
foot down but
adding stuff and trying out what the
fans kind of are
clamoring for and getting rewards and
them actually doing it and to me
this episode was in a way a love letter
to die hard fans of the handmaid's tale
since season one
and the reason i say that is because
it's kind of what i've been
praising the show for originally and i
thought it got
lost in season three where it's sticking
to the core
of what we loved about season one and
stuff they set up in season one and this
season already in particular this
episode really feels like
they listened to fans who wanted to come
back to our roots here and
i'm saying that because it was nick
missing last season right that was a big
thing fans didn't like
but him coming back to the fold is
really important in particular this
episode because
he's so integral to jun's character and
because we're seeing the show mostly
through june's
point of view and june's r connection
him in a sense then is integral to us
when reviewing this show and this
episode is plotted brilliantly and the
reason i'm saying that is because
everything here has a purpose but also
that
when nick says to june if you don't tell
me where they are i can't help you
please let me help you this is one of
the first lines the episode nick says to
june talking about the handmaids that
are on the run
and it burntly sets up what's going to
happen this episode and nick's
motivations and june's motivations
and june right now it plays like a
horror film
like most of the season has and this
show needs to be put in the genre of
horror as well now like officially but
it also plays
a lot like something you'd see in a war
film and we're in a war now right
so june is that soldier that isn't gonna
ever give up her people here she's too
honorable she's always for the right
cause
but it brilliantly has a justified
reason and what would actually make
june break and we would believe and
that's hannah and
that we get this reveal that nick is the
one behind
this hannah plan to get june to break
and that he's doing it because he loves
june and he wants june to
stay alive now what i did like too is
aunt lydia was brought right away into
the fold here she had very important
scenes
very important character building and i
also like
they introduce his new villain the
lieutenant and what's great about the
lieutenant already
he's worse than anyone you've ever seen
and that's important when you introduce
a new villain in any show you want to
keep topping the past villain by making
them more insane and crazy and this dude
is just weird
and i love how weird he is but the way
he's just so
casual about it and he just does some
awful things in this episode to the
point of waterboarding june
and ironically does it with a rag with a
cross on it just
religious hypocrites of course and
lydia even in that moment was so
important because she was even
just sewing there but that was getting
to her and i love how they always show
little moments of humanity that aunt
lydia in herself suppresses
because you're seeing this episode june
how far can she go to her breaking point
but you're also seeing lydia
on the other side of that and how much
lydia can just watch and stand by
bruce miller is a master at writing he
always comes through in the show
reason why he's the show runner and he
had a lot of great payoffs writing wise
and that comes to
june having this moment with lydia and
calling her out
for things being her fault and letting
her girls trying to hit her weak spots
that she failed them and that she let
them get raped humiliated and saying
it's her fault but that will come back
around
because lydia once she gets the win here
will say to june that
this is all her fault and she kind of
throws it back at her which i thought
was really interesting which we'll get
to but i will say
i love the directing of elizabeth moss's
episode she
really does a lot of handheld camera
work but she also likes her close-ups
which maybe would have been
a little bit overused in other episodes
but i think it really worked here
and she definitely is the director in
believing in intimacy and keeping you in
the moment and getting point of views of
characters in the scenes putting you
there
and she also has a lot of horror
influence obviously she's been in some
horror films and
recently an invisible man and you can
see she's inspired by a lot of that it
felt like you're watching a song movie
or hostel
and i love that she had these dark red
corridors and also the
flickering effect she had in the
elevator and she would even see her in a
crate straight out of a horror movie
here so you could tell she's very into
that
kind of genre but the one critique i
will give
of blocking which i thought was strange
was actually in this scene with
lydia and june because when she's
calling lydia out for all this stuff
she's done
it's just awkward like lydia's leaving
the room and then she's like
sit down you miserable beasts and she
like awkwardly goes to the door comes
back then awkwardly puts jean back in
her chair the whole thing felt a little
off
but that was like one of the small
critiques i had of the whole episode but
not many but thank god we didn't have to
watch her fingernail get pulled by the
lieutenant here that was like i
just closed my eyes like i can't even i
like gore and i like saw movies but that
would just that
would be way too much and she avoids it
by doing her lie here about where the
handmaids are and she'll have to pay
consequences for that which we'll get to
but i do want to shift years for a
second
to where it cuts to moira and luke's
story and luke's really breaking down
here which i like like
they're really putting forward momentum
now in the candidate players here and
it's much needed because they've been
stalled in previous seasons
and i feel like they're setting luke up
to have like a meltdown but maybe in a
good way that he needs to have that
he needs to do something here instead of
just sitting down you see he's
frustrated
he's frustrated they're just saying
prayers but june he learns is imprisoned
so
i like that they had this whole good
luck bearing
that fruit that he wants and he's just
trying for anything at this point a
little faith he has and
that was planted by the government woman
earlier in the episode
about that she would do that so i think
luke has a little bit of a fire
coming under him now and that it's
desperately needed and it's going to be
interesting to see what happens with
luke but i have good
vibes i feel like they're going the
right way with his character i feel like
this whole episode was forward momentum
because it was so focused on the main
plot which i really appreciated it
didn't feel that stretch we felt
in season three now what really hit me
was when we get this amazing rooftop
sequence or it's pouring rain and really
jun's got a face now which is
to deal with that's just horrible which
is seeing beth
and sienna from last season who lived
with her
on the roof now and what i felt watching
this episode was
it was like a tour for june through
june's eyes and the audience eyes for us
all the characters that affected june
significantly that goes to lawrence
lydia nick and then seeing the effect of
her
losing majority of her girls here
this was an episode that really just
shakes things
up and we hit some conflict some
consequences
and this is stuff that's like the title
the crossing it's a crossing for june's
character it's a crossing over for the
show
and we see literally it's the crossing
at the end of the episode with the train
tracks
and june crossing over it's really one
of the best things you can do in a
season four of a show
a lot of shows season four is when shows
really drop off it's kind of like the
consensus here that
most shows are going for a while season
four is when you start to see equality
decline but
i'm just so impressed how good this
still is in a season four and that's
actually going up from the past season
to me
and you see i love they let beth say
don't tell them a word it kind of
she's giving june a clear conscience
here about what's happening like no i'm
with you here we're not saying [ __ ]
and you just see the lieutenant just
pushes her like that's how cruel this
guy is but
again just does it so casual he's a very
interesting villain already it's
actually interesting to watch but you
can see this was tougher in june
with sienna who's younger here she's got
a more innocent vibe she's not just
vocally saying like beth was like yeah
don't say anything we're doing this so
it's really conflicting for june but you
understand that where june is like
why would she change right now like
she's gone this far doing stuff like
this this is
war right rules change there's gonna be
sacrifices june understands this
and i'm glad they didn't have her just
like chicken out here
again we needed if arjun who we know is
stubborn like they say and will do
anything for the just cause
is gonna break it has to be something
believable and that was so important
here and they nailed that
again with hannah now one of my favorite
scenes in this episode was actually with
nick and lawrence it's a perfect scene
that you should do
in any writing of television or film
because every line counts here
it's to the point and it gets what it
needs to get done and it justifies
the season thread but also serves the
plot of the episode
because we're seeing this newer nick now
he's a commander he's got power so it's
always interesting to see him as a
commander like what
he can do to protect himself from
getting in trouble but the power he has
to use to help june
and what he's willing to put on the line
and i love that like
lawrence is kind of sitting back you
know he's happy he's just
in his old house but nick's like no no
like you owe me man like i got you
to stay alive here you know we're not
done and i like that he's
pushing lawrence and making him face
like no you're not just letting june go
here like because
lawrence has this line like she's done
so much good things she's fulfilled her
purpose but it's time for us to move on
and nick's like nah like
i can't like i and you know nick still
loves june
and it's interesting because it's got to
be a hard choice even for nick and how
june is going to eventually then they
react this because
he is the catalyst that put hannah there
it was his idea and he knew that was the
only way june was going to actually say
where the handmaids were
but at the same time he's doing it
because he knows the only way stubborn
june is going to
stay alive he wants her to stay alive so
he's saving her
but is it against her cause we'll see
how that all kind of settles into june
as we go on through the season i just
want to give props too this is just a
scene with june and lawrence
the acting here they're always great
these two actors but this was just
special you know you know when there's
scenes like that and they're both giving
it all and
i was just blown away because the way
they're talking about hannah
and then jun not really believing him
and that she he she thinks
he might be bluffing it was just
incredible the back and forth and that
lawrence is just this character you like
and then you don't like and that he's
kind of a chicken at the end of the day
too and he's like i'm at the end of the
rope here i can't do much but she's
kind of calling him out i just love how
that all set up to the scene with her
seeing hannah and actually realizing
like no he wasn't kidding like hannah's
there and
props to the production design in this
episode especially in the scene with
hannah and the cube i love just
the rooms are in in this show that room
in general when you first see it
it just has this like green lit walls
that are pretty cool and i know this
must have been hard because this was
filmed
really in the height of covid times and
they're getting just creative and where
this like
underground layer they're in for gilead
so i just think
it was just really interesting to see
but what really works and i think the
episode started getting really good was
when she sees hannah because
like i was talking about the beginning
of my review of like going back to
season one
and what we love about this show we know
june's main motivation everything she
does is really about hannah at the end
of the day
and protecting hannah and getting hannah
out of there and having her face hannah
again
is significant and you see it's
significant because hannah is older now
so that's also going to affect june and
seeing that
but like her alliances later on she's
also seeing she's afraid of june
and not afraid of the people she should
be so it's haunting it's
heartbreaking and it was really
effectively done in that elizabeth
monster's directing let it
sit there and let it sit her looking at
hannah for just the right amount of time
to make you feel that and it's her one
week spot and she gives up the location
and guys like jun's not gonna let
hannah get hurt here like she's not
thanos
there's your nerdy marvel reference
because then she'd be unlikable because
no one would do that
yeah she doesn't want to give up these
handmaids at any cost but come on she's
not gonna let someone just hurt her kid
and i loved loved this scene where lydia
now has a pep in her step she comes to
june
and june's the complete opposite like
she's completely broken here
and i love how elizabeth moss just acts
the scene says these lines
again great writing she's like lydia i
am ready
i'm ready for this all to be over kill
me and
lydia's like not one handmade can be
spared
she's now down for this idea she said
she was originally hesitant about which
is like this breeding colony where
they would work all day and then they
basically do the ceremonies
it's just a horrible idea and that's the
last thing june wants to hear
now i think a complaint i'm predicting a
lot of fans are going to have with this
scene in this moment is that
you gotta go there is no way they would
keep june alive after they got the info
they needed from her right she's the
biggest threat to gilead she's already
proven how much she's capable of she got
all these kids on a plane
and it was what i was saying to how it
wasn't buying how they'd keep lawrence
alive
in episode one and of course here it's
pretty unbelievable that they keep june
alive she's more of a liability i know
handmaids
are very precious to them and valuable
because of the fertility crisis
in gilead's eyes but come on anyone
would know that it's more risky to even
keep june alive
but i don't see it as what people are
going to say as like oh it's plot armor
for june which they always say but
i always say that plot armor i will
excuse
for the main characters of shows because
that is how a show is gonna operate
that's tv that's something i'm always
willing to suspend disbelief because
there's gonna be plot armor for every
single show you've watched of every
single main character you've seen and
that's movies too that's just essential
because then it's just not going to
happen like the story won't go on you
can't just say
okay june's going to get put on the wall
then what then the show's over
so i get it you know there's this i mean
you can only
write so many ways to make it as
realistic as possible but you know
i i don't hold that against the show
like it's four seasons people like they
can't make their number one goal that
every time
you know june survives another day it
has to perfectly be realistic it just
doesn't happen really in anything and i
think people understand for that i say
plot armor i understand
other characters no and that's where i'm
going to say a complaint because i do
think
they actually wrote lydia too harsh here
to make you hate her so much that you're
like
i don't really buy necessarily june
wouldn't kill her in that moment after
everything lydia just said to her
and sang the all your fault thing back
to her i was like okay so then june at
the end of the episode i would fully
expect her to kill lydia in that moment
that there wasn't any
redeeming qualities for her at that
point so i think they might have
actually
pushed her too hard here lydia to make
us really not
buy maybe that june wouldn't kill her so
that i will critique so like i said
giving
a moment here that's a crowd pleaser is
having nick and june reunite on the
bridge here and him saying i love you to
her and she loves her
and that he says sorry for what he had
to do but i do think there's a part of
june obviously that gets it
and gets what nick did and she says line
you know she was scared of me
talking about hannah she wasn't scared
of them which i thought was great and
you see when they kiss
i like this moment you know some people
might see this as cheesy but elizabeth
moss
directing decides to do that 360 degree
turn around them and that happy music
comes in but i think you need this in
such a bleak show in a bleak episode
in general it's a little moment of hope
and happiness and just
kind of to get her head why june would
go from being completely suicidal to
actually getting a little hope again
with nick but i do wonder
so the guards that brought nick in i
could get that they wouldn't be
suspicious
of nick and june kissing because those
are probably knowing nick has power
two people he really trusts and kind of
know that nick is something else up his
sleeve
however i'm confused by the truck that
saw on the other end
june and nick and came to pick up june
is that the same
car that lydia and all them are in why
wouldn't that guardian be more alerted
and weary about them kissing so that i
thought was a little
confusing and off okay so now we get to
the big moment where we're in the lydia
mobile
with all of the handmaids right we get
to the crossing title the episodes train
tracks here
and the guardians got to pee now in my
screeners i get
they're very early and they're like very
fresh cut so
i see a lot of the markers actors got to
hit you know you'll see some green
screen stuff
and we don't have final music or final
sound quality so i can't judge a lot of
those things
but i don't know what's in the final cut
when i'm recording this but what was in
my screener was
radiohead which is my favorite band and
they play the song street spirit fade
out which i thought was completely
perfect the sequence i hope it was in
the final cut here
and i got the rights to it because it
was perfect for this
whole scene and this scene was a
mastercraft in editing cutting between
the close-ups and point of views
elizabeth moss chose to do of the
handmaids here in lydia and
it was perfectly decision to have them
running in slo-mo away from the car
i thought this was such a freeing moment
for these handmaids
a rebellious winning moment with this
radiohead blasting again
why is there plot armor for and out here
it's and down i don't think they want to
cut loose that actress so
that's gonna happen too but again maybe
they just wrote her too harsh
in an earlier scene because i don't
really buy it june wouldn't kill her
there
yes i know june's seen some humanity of
aunt lydia but at that point i don't
know man i think it was long gone
but this again sequence was just crazy
and then running straight
for the train tracks and then this
guardian shooting them hearing the
gunshots in the back
losing handmaids and then unfortunately
we get the death of alma and brianna
and we just have june and jeannine
left wow now if you know my reviews and
you've seen my interviews i'm a huge fan
of alma not just the character but
the actress nina kiri so this was really
hard for me it was hard for me that this
decision was made it was
past just the show for me so i got very
emotional of course i cried
and i think this was one of the most
spiritual show moments for me and i mean
by that is
you've been with these handmaids these
are the og handmaids right
from the beginning and that's why i
thought what really landed was them
doing
this sequence that's like this heavenly
sequence right where they're all in
white
and they're in the beds holding hands
and you get the narration of june
and that magical handmade score kicks in
with the violins that
always bring the tears and with that
overhead shot above them and
it was so rewarding to me and it
meant so much because i'm talking about
why i open this review saying how it
goes back to season one this is the og
stuff right this is the crossing for the
show
too it's like kind of kissing goodbye to
it too and that
we got that connection now we're gonna
see where all those connections with
season one lead
june now and they got her through and
it's
so sad but it works so well and seeing
you know again alma pass was really
tough for me
i interviewed her all about this so you
can check the interview now
she's an awesome person she did
interview with me when i was
literally nobody and she still did the
interview so
that just tells you her character so
please check that out she's going to
talk all about this send
off for her and what she thought you'll
see that link below but what i love
about this episode like i said is that
it's like a
just a tour for june it's a tour for us
the handmaid's fan since the beginning
and you're seeing all these characters
that have affected her for good and for
bad that she's revisiting here
and it's pushing the plot forward it
ends on something forward now with
janine and her on the run
and that she got some sort of connection
and idea of what's going on
nick now and an idea what's going on
hannah and that
seems like we're moving luke along here
so i think that's all good without the
little nitpicks i had here with the
blocking
again with making me kind of not really
buy june not
killing lydia there that's only going to
bring it down a little bit but i think
it was a masterful debut for directing
frozen with moss
again great writing to bruce miller as
always great productions on great
editing
a great episode three i mean we're
already here so we're
not getting that stretching feeling we
felt in season two and three a lot of
this is like
feeling like season one again where
everything's counting here moving the
plot forward i hope it keeps up
because a lot of shows recently in
general they usually release the first
two episodes
and the third episode is usually amazing
like this but then it kind of peaks i
hope this doesn't peak and it just keeps
it up
i have faith though the handmaid's tale
team is one of the best and just in
general we've seen where we've gone
how many shows right now are still so
good in a season four so props to the
handmaid's tale i'm gonna give this
episode a 9.6
i really wanted to give it a 10 but
again i can't ignore
some of those nitpicks i have and that
questionable thing too about that van
seeing them and how he'd be okay with
nick and june kissing but overall i'm
really excited about where this is gonna
go
this was an awesome episode it's gonna
be tough to top this season
and i'm excited to see more of elizabeth
moss's work as a director
and i'm excited to see the reactions
episode i think it's gonna be
interesting if it is hitting for people
like it did for me
or if it's not i love to hear it all so
let me know down below i read every
comment i try to respond as many as i
can please check out
all the interviews i've done with the
handmaid's tale team there's a bunch of
new ones
you're gonna want to watch them they're
linked below and please if you like what
i do here
i ask for a two dollar monthly donation
it will help me do this full time one
day
and make more videos for you guys
there's a paypal link for that down
below
and you can also subscribe to the
channel in general that helps me in so
many
ways as well and that's completely free
i'd love if you do that praise be
and i'll see you next time